hello there I'm Colby rebel I am a
professional psychic medium hi I'm
Elizabeth south I'm a private detective
with cane associates and I have a job
today
today we're gonna find out who the real
person is that committed a crime which
one of these guys is telling the truth I
feel totally fine going head-to-head
with a psychic if she's the best psychic
in the world I think it's interesting
and I'd like to talk to her afterwards
let us see what we have here all right
let's see how serious this crime is when
I was 17 I got caught trying to throw a
giant co-ed party at my parents house
while they were staying 15 minutes away
all right well obviously not the
brightest criminal we've got back here
but let's see how this plays out
how funny the same thing happened to me
let's see who is my sister or brother in
crime here's the deal look a little
petite one here she looks like she'd be
throwing a party while the parents are
15 minutes away so I don't think it's
her you had you look kind of malicious I
don't know why you're like mean-mugging
me like can you smile a little bit
what's this he's like don't ask me
questions I think we got Little Miss
innocent college girl here or here I'm
so sweet smart got my glasses on it
couldn't have been me so these are my my
initial feelings well we'll see how they
go
hello I'm air what's your first name
Megan Megan so what did your parents do
when they found out oh you didn't do it
okay so your parents caught you or who
caught you no one caught me doing
anything you're just trying to tell me
that this was not you how was the party
really fun really fun so how could the
party be really fun if you just said you
didn't do it I don't know I don't I I
feel like every question you asked is
just gonna be me going I don't know I
didn't do it and then where were your
parents when oh at the time of the party
if there were 15 minutes away where were
they I don't know what party okay all
right and so are your parents still
together yeah tell me about how they
were their personalities
my dad is like the funny one and my mom
is like the emotional therapist II sort
of won and when you were 17 you were
still in high school
so when you had the party what made you
decide that you could have the party you
know doesn't make a lot of sense
so I don't know what would you describe
their mantra' on raising a child as very
again open loving understanding all
right so they're not gonna be like
really strict with things yeah that's
what made it so easy to just go do what
I wanted I'm so jealous my parents were
so strict I had to lie about everything
I think I've lied about what I thought
actually but you had the party you
weren't going to a party didn't have the
party that says you had the party it
doesn't it says it doesn't say Meghan I
don't know you tell me you didn't even
look at it but you read it all right
Thank You Meghan okay mm-hmm I'm gonna
go with you honey what's your first name
Merle Merle all right Merle so tell me
about how good or bad or what you did do
what we did I did I did I did would you
- I was 17 I had never thrown a party I
was kind of like the friend who would
like go to my other friend's house they
relate the hosts so I was like I need
you this one's mom in high school and
then where were your parents my mom and
my dad were at a hotel they're like
trying to rekindle things so they
divorced now yes did they do this often
no it wasn't it was like kind of a rough
patch like it was getting pretty bad oh
this is so bad all right go ahead tell
me about your fun party story okay I was
like all right I'm gonna throw a party
there was a guy who's like a couple
accused in college now he's a couple
years older and I really wanted to
become because I wanted to hang out with
him I'm going to hang out with him yeah
so I mean like three of my friends
Tiffany Shana and Katherine all really
great time tonight
did you get caught having the party yeah
how hot like 50 well because so I have
an old dog herb we did have an old dog
passed away her name is Lily and so she
was sick and my mom wanted to come back
and check on her she want to make sure
that we like to give her medicine and
like took care of her and we almost got
her to leave but then she decided to
come in anyway why didn't she just text
you to check on Lily she had she
actually called me three times but I was
so busy like putting vodka in the
freezer and like trying to spruce up the
place that I just like didn't have my
phone and so I didn't I didn't see it
and how did your dad react my dad was
like kind of more he knows my mom and I
are super super close like we're fine
but he's kind of similar to your dynamic
or he's like the funnier one and so
he knows I'm gonna listen to my mom more
than him and he was like disappointed
but he wasn't like you're the worst kid
ever because I'd never done it before
you're pretty good kid other than that a
pretty good kid did the boy come to the
boy take comedy had to stop because I
got trouble so like it didn't nothing
end up happening but with the party
though how long did the party go on
before you got caught I would say
probably like an hour and a half hour it
could have been two hours but like there
weren't a ton of people there for the
first hour so it kind of like was just
getting going when my mom came back I
might bring you back might bring you
back down to sit down I'm good on you hi
there hi what's your first name hair
Rachel I'm guessing you're gonna tell me
you were guilty for something oh my god
see far a lot um no I did I did have a
party in high school that I did get
caught trying to make I mean the moment
in which I got caught up wasn't that bad
to me because I had thrown parties
before it's always bad because I was
inviting a lot of people to it what made
you decide to have a party so my
neighbor like it was like a cool girl
and so she moved him when I was like 13
and I always wanted to do things to like
impress her so she runs with my cousin
and my cousin was coming over and they
decided to talk about this and I
definitely went along with it so how'd
you get caught okay so they had went to
my cousin's house for the night and like
my older cousin was over with me my
cousin Aaron
but her younger brother they went to
like babysit because their parents but
but then the parents came back because
they had booked the wrong date and so my
parents came back to the house and it
was like already an hour - after they
had left so there was only a couple of
people over how many people were there
okay so the silver lining is that I got
caught but for like the massive amount
of people are coming so there was only
like 25 people there
okay he's already in trouble for that
when they came back they were just kind
of disappointed that's it you didn't
really get in trouble or no they were
they were like really mad about it I
think I don't know how exactly they had
found out that like dudes were coming
but I think it was either like they
walked into Muse on the phone or like
somebody came to the door like while
they were in the house getting pissed
about this crap and that's when like
there were like annoying me and there
were six guys that showed and they were
like what were you doing and what was
the punishment I don't know who's gonna
feel like a couple of weeks but I mean
it was like us
reaming thing in front of like 25 people
all right would you do it again yeah I
mean I got grounded for like I don't
know like three weeks like what okay got
it okay thank you thank you sir
the very happy one yeah try me so quiet
I know I'm trying to play the part I
don't know what story you're gonna tell
me so I guess give it to here so this
was around October I was 217 and I
wanted to throw a costume party I tell
her brothers but they don't want to do
it because they knew like my parents
were gonna be gone for not sure how long
cuz I was just on my Godfather's house
so I was like you know what whatever I
was gonna do it and did you get in
trouble I did what was your punishment
well my dad was one of those like like
in front of my mom he had to like look
mad and then when I just him and I was
like was it fun I was like yeah it was
why was that you got parents house they
just don't like random like nice and
drinking sometimes how did they catch
you they're my Godfather's house and
they just randomly came home I was a
little intoxicated and then my friend is
like you know your parents here I turn
around my mom's face is like like that's
my job to know and so it was just you
who put it together and your brother
they bought the alcohol for me the older
brother yeah okay so they bought you the
alcohol and then what happened I mean
they use an excuse to party too but they
didn't want to be involved in the ones
like starting it like the party so when
they told my parents say nothing to do
with it why did they randomly come home
with oh my dad sometimes once they come
home just gotta save cuz he works a lot
so I was like 11:00 at night and he just
came on what was your punishment my mom
just didn't talk to me for a week and I
mean I know it's not that bad Bo and
your mom doesn't talk to you
like you can't you literally can't do
anything really I see my god I'm so glad
you got nice so awkward for a minute I
feel pretty good there's definitely some
good Little Liars back here that's for
sure
I think I know who it is I am not quite
sure if I know who had the party yet so
now it is time for the big reveal and to
see if either of us got this right
do you feel confident no this one I
thought was hard they're really
convincing these these guys but we're
gonna give it a go
right
[Music]
we're going to show this yes Megan
tomorrow you Megan I got I got a zero
information from was a hard one yeah
she's like I just didn't do it no have
you done anything nope I don't have
parties I don't drink I know I've never
seen a can of beer in my life I could be
totally wrong but I just kept hearing
it's her it's definitely not the guy
there's no way it's not him
if it's him I'm gonna laugh cuz I was
like yeah it's not him okay okay I don't
know look okay culprit oh that's what
I'm just gonna say like okay well tell
me about your history I told a lot of
truth like I never got in trouble I
basically never drank so I had no good
reason to throw a party but my parents
were going fifty minutes away to
rekindle the romance and I just got
convinced into it by some bad friends I
had invited like 20 people co-ed we had
four handles of vodka and a rack of beer
and I had a sick dog I told you didn't I
oh you're a toy I want to let you know I
don't like you now wait wait so let's
get this straight número is a liar and a
thief and she can copy anything she's
not even original yes my name is Megan
and when I was 17 I got caught trying to
throw a giant co-ed party when my
parents were staying 15 minutes away
[Music]
[Music]